right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 39 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
got a very special guest
respawn acquisition news sports games as
a service and of course the console
launch of the Beast to discuss so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a Lord whose contact content I
was initially introduced to my co-host
for that this law provides very high
quality tech and gaming news which is
always broken down with humor in a clear
and concise format although this Lords
content is predominately Xbox centric
he's always willing to back his own
opinions with facts
it is never afraid to engage in
intellectual debate regarding topics he
is most passionate about introducing the
creator and host of the real deal xbox
podcast the leader of tech tangents and
one of the top five youtube
personalities in the game it's been a
long time coming for the Reaper and real
deal in these Xbox treats my way Lord
dealer gaming how you doing sir wow you
put all kinds of spice on that intro
[Laughter]
Sunday morning for for for a lot of us
and it's good to be here and I do
appreciate the invite I never been here
before
always looking for these kinds of
experiences a lot of good stuff to talk
about today thanks for a meal absolutely
much appreciated huge fan of your work
your Lord at what you do so we had to
roll out the red carpet for you of
course we have the usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the Como's my brother
from another mother
and the how of the
Wolfe's madmen Lord addict now you doing
sin king shut your mouth I know you're
tempted you know it's a miracle I made
it this week angle I to you guys I would
do a lot of we appreciate you bro we
know you go and do it and of course the
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience Xbox Live profile is
weak love it Lord sovereign how you
doing sir profile is live all week
answer it's like all over the place
that's what that's right that's very
impressive we're very impressed
it was so bad when you go on his profile
says this dude ain't been off since
yesterday and of course the excess gamer
the lord of combat sports who was a man
of his convictions puts it all on the
line and demands nothing less in the
premium experience be loving Lord King
how you doing sir we're great yeah baby
Miller versus a tomato can yesterday and
he did what he does still committed to
mate Oh candy crushes him yeah that was
great
all right yeah Danny Jacobs versus arias
and I anticipated a better fight areas
had a lot of talk Danny Jacobs watch
this boy for 12
round straight he woulda knocked him out
cuz he was a seeking destroy mode but it
didn't go down like that for the simple
fact the dude was running look at the
irony when I say this because he pointed
to Daddy Jenkins before the fight
started and said look bro
don't run and he had on track shoes
gonna be that dude beat I do please I'm
fast off to my co-host over here for the
USC real quick because I'm pretty sure
that the UFC had something last night
that I gotta check into yeah I mean
actually I can't kind of quote the end
of it I'm gonna catch the main car but
you have my boy Showtime Pettis he got
he got his a Ripper
it's just inferred a put it on him so he
won that joint I actually missed the
cause I gotta catch up probably UFC
fight pass that on the Xbox app to see
what the rest was going on but um yeah
big car last night Dustin Poirier in
Showtime
and of course it is Lord Cardinal here
and that gaming realness on the IOP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to do with the Lord's a
plane I want to start with more deal on
this video game system history the
creation of the dealer gaming YouTube
channel and of course that amazing RDX
podcasts oh lordy let's start from the
beginning like what were the first video
game systems that she had and he started
with hmm actually that was the same
night I found out Santa Claus wasn't
real it was I do believe that was my
first system I was a [ __ ] I don't
know I was a lot of type of kid but yeah
I got a Sega Genesis and then from there
I moved on from that to Super NES and
then ps1 and I remember thinking when I
saw how Silent Hill and ps1 I was like
there is no way games are gonna look any
better than this
go back you look at it now it is
literally just pixels crawling on the
screen so
it's insane we progressed absolutely
phenomenal time to be a gamer especially
in the Xbox side as you guys know yeah
absolutely
we're went nice but so they're now a
from you progressed on to the Xbox like
did you would you uh one of the original
og Xbox systems that was the first one
or did you jump in like doing a 360 era
uh I had a ps2 like everyone else had a
ps1 like everyone else I decided to jump
into the Xbox and see what that was all
about first game was actually Robo tech
on the Xbox nice pretty pretty cool game
I guess mecha Souls probably the game
that got me most curious about Xbox I I
remember looking at that old you know
that old TV I think it was at Walmart
they had these old TVs and you look up
and see all the whatever the Xbox is ps2
games mech assault was up there I was
like man that destruction even as a kid
was next level to me you know you'd run
into the building's they crack and
crumble and then it was just nuts
looking so I had to get into the Xbox
and from there you know I feel after I
murdered the first burglar in my house
with that use the thing as a weapon so I
just kind of kind of really embraced the
platform around the original Xbox being
able to put my own music on the console
listen to it in about all year
soundtracks all what was it a 40
megabyte no it was like a 10 gigabyte
hard drive up I don't remember it was so
small but I filled all of it up with
music and I just gamed man so original
Xbox definitely fell in love with that
one
so you filled it up with music and then
realized you had nothing no more room to
put games are gonna save some stuff now
Leeson Park to pull that PlayStation 2
days you had to beat the whole game
about the memory I think I I had to
leave that thing on for a little bit
when I first got I didn't have my phone
I remember back in the day man I must
have been like allegedly an 80s like I
don't know if I was taking very well
because I used to play the Final Fantasy
games without a memory card and then
thank you got it now like how much time
I wasted like in custom soundtracks the
dealer definitely bring me back with
that so don't you progress now what got
you to start like your own YouTube
channel getting like what like like a
lot of you guys I used to watch people
start watching first I mean I probably
stumbled onto disease channel next to
720 you know and he was the one guy out
there bullets flying past this head
representing the Xbox you know I was
excited for the Xbox one I felt like
people should be allowed to do that and
and unfortunately he wasn't back then
there they were like him or hate him
that's a dude that got me into this
but I was watching a lot of people I
think I was kind of introduced a kid and
and and gosh everyone [ __ ] quit but
yeah I mean nobody hardly does it
anymore but yeah ultimately the game
that got me to make my first video so
was um was destiny what a big piece of
[ __ ] oh my god it was like the most I'm
not even gonna go short guys destiny one
got me to make a video about it and I
used to make daily videos and I just
grind it and I grind it every single day
add a video out and man I remember
sitting in for subscribers for like what
felt like forever
shoutout to the fifth [ __ ] you
know so many my benefit fees in the chat
says I remember we're dealing with a
young buck yeah anchorman was one of
them out there as well so we all shout
out man
so then you progress you start the bill
you got that channel popping and then we
got that amazing RDX
tell me about how that started that just
started from a kind of a whim just to
want to be on a more constructed podcast
I guess right keep it real got a panel
of very mixed opinions and racist too
you know we got a lot of cool in there
we got guys that won just PlayStation
this generation there were 360 guys last
generation we got myself an Xbox guy but
I got a you know a decent gaming PC Cole
would kind of the same thing but he
moved to yeah oh yeah so we got a really
diverse cast of people we try to keep it
about an hour long get a lot of
information out there very quickly
unlike what I'm doing exactly right now
and of course it's early come on guys so
we just tried to do what we do and have
a great time we have a good turnout
every week and we appreciate the support
I appreciate you man a shout-out to the
team because I definitely respect all
the guys and gal you got on there Luca
Cole Southwire rock when I met we drank
the government Cali so I was good people
man and I blue team all - I just want
yeah he's been all days been working
before them basically the day of the
show trying to get things in order for
the X and he did that so he should be
back more often you got Jay Fonzarelli
you got a KA fraud oh really
he was absolutely just blown away by
assassins creed last night I mean this
guy was nice so yeah good team nice nice
good team and we like what you're doing
out there
waste are very informative and you got
you guys putting work so we had to
salute the Lord's definitely you know
RDX is definitely an amazing podcast
it's so good they like you need to
switch your days because it was not
showing up on the list like that blows
my mind yeah fun week we got stuff to
talk about stuff things going on so
let's first get into what the Lords of
plants are let's start Lord dealer what
have you been touching this week on xbox
man I've been planning everything
literally everything so as you guys know
we've had a rough time we were here on
Xbox for a little bit not too much to
play so yeah I've been playing
everything that's been coming out
battlefront 2 looks absolutely
phenomenal on the ax Wolfenstein to
easily win the best game for the last
couple years looks absolutely phenomenal
on the X yes floors of motorsport 7 I
know life from the s I've gotten the
elite trophy and on every podium so I
100% for the 7 G's what else sacis Creed
origins losing my life to that I can I
can just I don't know it's so weird to
have so much to play in such a short
amount of time what else man she
everything's a good life everything is
live I got it and I'm playing it play it
hey you say everything is a little worse
- part of that
hey lures to already be like twice I
mess with Halo Wars - but I did play it
and it does look pretty good I remember
you saying someone said that but it
actually does look pretty good in 4k
pretty much ultra settings is what it
looks like to me I played it at e3 and
it wasn't really how it looked it's how
it played that I was impressed by cuz
you know uh Halo Wars 2 has a lot of
framerate issues like you know when
stuff's going down like when what when
it gets to the point real like you know
I need help that's when the frames go
and when I was playing at e3 on the X it
wasn't dropping at all like you could
have 30 Scorpius fighting each other 20
Grizzly's all in the same battlefield
and it wasn't going nowhere
mm-hmm speaking of 30 we got about 32
people watching live guys hit that like
button help support the paw commands we
appreciate though thank you
so my co-host Lord added what have you
been playing this week uh I just got a
PlayStation that I haven't played yet
you know let me let me say this real
quick make it quick
the Lord Kabbalah - I know that you're
gonna get onto me for this but I'm not
filling persona I'm sorry but it's not
that it's a bad game it just might not
be for me is what it is it is what is
sometimes games like that you know
sometimes games like that no no so what
about on the only exercise whatever you
been playing I don't have an ex oh we
don't that's right but I mean on the on
the s excuse me I like I was playing
some telltale games universe of the rest
of us right now podcast in the upside
down right now planets are I'm pretty
sure and strange things in the upside
down word I would still be playing the
ex friend okay but it would be about the
ex oh man a lot of people give you know
there is one great thing that's come out
of this cross whatever the hell you want
to call it mutation of a iterative
upgrade is you're not locked out of your
friends anymore you're not locked out of
your game controllers your headsets
everything just works and if you don't
want to play the AXA fee you know you're
are you know there's no point saying
well you shouldn't get one because it's
all it's on option you know so yeah
forcing you to do so and then you still
play with a decanas Atari and and we
better now because I'm Way too young a
lot of stuff man just going back and
checking everything in the library that
I kind of took up my entire week died
finally so like the last last couple of
days finally just getting into
Wolfenstein some shadow of war and NBA
Assassin's Creed the Assassin's Creed
has taken me over yeah
for caged y'all goodness that's uh yeah
and on the Swiss side that pulled me
away from Mario but I picked it up put
my money where my mouth is and I picked
up that doom pick that ring at 30 frames
yeah it's it's people like you that's
the reason there whatever it takes
tastes kind of support so yeah it's
doing the game is a hundred percent
intact it is by far the ugliest version
and you don't die you don't you know
what else it's all deportable ever ever
ever ever darker it gets explodes it
never really hits that 720 anywhere so
uh but it is a small miracle that game
so let me let me answer this right let
me ask you this do you think that it's
fair that's a switch version of doom is
braided like higher than the ps4 or Xbox
version not at all I mean I think the
portability means a lot to somebody who
I mean just because the portability
don't mean nothing when it's had
resolution that yeah right what's up in
64 games that but I'm not at all not at
all the the console versions blow that
game away not even trying in terms of
looks terms of speed like but again like
I said it's a small Merkel they got that
game onto that system and the fact well
I know everybody sit there say you ain't
for the [ __ ] kid would you rather it
not be on saying like preface in it like
that it's working on the game the game
is out when you have to start every
conversation what it is Nintendo just
stated that is the game over in the
Tendo and this is a good looking game
for Nintendo that's it no that's not
that's not a favor system to make it
funny
[Laughter]
why would I preface it with that but on
real note let's move on pay some bills
right now shoutout to Calvin W that's in
Texas for the cape variants also Victor
P that's in North Carolina shout out to
him forgetting the King experience they
also receive iron Lords podcast t-shirts
with a loot crate that came with the
Xbox one elite situation it was a good
thing for them appreciate it greats come
with a list I put other stuff that was
in there but they t-shirts with in there
as well because character fire alright
anyway I've been playing everything guys
like literally to my 360 shoutouts a
Ferrara's edge because please Scott out
to the only time people are playing
their game or Colbert is in a chat for -
yesterday I was blown away again like
all the games they weren't up to snuff I
went back to check I really didn't get a
chance to get some a new catalog I did
play my sassy screen though but it's
just so much Oh Lord Ram thank you so
much for putting me on to that cactus
game um it's it's an indie game
it's a twin stick shooter it's xbox
enhance the game runs beautiful
it looks beautiful shut up you're
putting that up yesterday you have so
much stuff to play it is insane the
first time I think a video game history
that I'm able to plug in my new system
and it enhanced all my old games hmm I
see the only reason another reason
you're getting a pass cuz I mean
assassin's creed just can't make like oh
trying to play some Mirror's Edge I
think it's acceptable seeing is that
game at least runs in 4k
somebody told me somebody tweeted out
mirrors edge mirror's edge brought her
disgrace
whoever you are guys I guess I will rest
in peace in the same boat man just ever
since I got it's been going through the
whole backlog and I mean even throughout
fallout 3 just to see you know it popped
up on my reading install list just to
see him it just feels like a high-end PC
port it's so clean you know all the new
games but I didn't go through everything
just yet but that's well get into on the
topic but as far as like our rankings as
far as where we feel certain these X
titles are but it's really beautiful to
see some of these games in 4k and shout
out to HDR man doesn't get enough credit
a CEO is really a game changer in my
opinion that's pretty much what I've
been doing as far as just going through
the catalog so last week we had a poll
and the poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the Xbox one X launch day one adopters
what is the first type of title you
launch on your shiny new X the winner
the 50 percent in a competitive three
way poll was that I'm playing the newer
third-party titles first so they agree
with lore dealer as if they would have
at 35 percent was the I'm playing older
xbox enhanced titles group no and coming
in at a fairly competitive third place
at fifteen percent was the forget age
I'm watching blu-ray and Netflix last
week's poll turnout was lit what do the
Lords think about that let's start with
look do you know what do you think about
the people what they saying I think all
of them are right because everyone's
different so if you want to watch Chef
[ __ ] Netflix is the first thing you
do on your ex and have at it right so I
kind of get tired of hearing people you
know you two playing all games for huh
like well I do have a lot of old games
that's right I do have like 400 games
thanks for knowing that but I also have
called duty Wolfenstein Assassin's Creed
Battlefront 2 and everything else is
coming out for now on that's going to be
enhanced you know and it's really weird
these people don't seem to understand
that that that's really what people use
the ps4 for for the first couple years
and now when the pro game out it didn't
launch with any exclusives at all but
the ex is getting hammered for it and
then you got Wolfenstein coming in at
over 8 million pixels a lot of the time
according to digital founder they say
they are surprised how much it holds
native 4k you've got the pro version at
3.6 million pixels and they're saying oh
it does a little bit more and this does
I have a high resolution texture pack by
the way so there's been very great
launch one on consoles so far that I
know of and I'm sure there's another one
because of course mafia 3 tomb raider
and of course shadow war high resolution
Ultra HD texture packs make the
difference and these are games that are
on both platforms the pro version does
not have these and I say in a video
released today as a matter of fact there
are two of me he'll release it around
11:00 my to you as I say today you know
these high-resolution texture packs are
this is the future this is what's going
to happen it's gonna be pushed by the ex
and PC and the pro is gonna be left out
in the cold air you know it's gonna be
icicles off of it seriously and people
don't really think about this stuff so
not only do you have much more potential
for
an actual native 4k image something
that's really gonna make that 4k TV
shine but those are extra pixels that
they could take and put into effects in
the future as games get more demanding
that Ram is gonna allow for high
resolution textures and I don't remember
why I'm even talking about this so
people are giving this thing enough
credit people aren't really thinking
hard enough they're testing games that
aren't even patched that's a great you
got a lot of opinions out there from
people who don't know what they're
talking about and they're downplaying
the system while they touted the Pro a
year ago so no absolutely ridiculous to
me but back to your question hey first
third party everything's gonna look
great on this thing Gears of War 4
absolutely astounding in 1080p 60 frames
per second what looks like to me ultra
settings I've seen it at Ultra several
times in the PC that's what it looks
like and that 60 is fairly locked over
90% of the time I mean people like to
pick one screen shot out and say I'll
look it runs at 40 frames no it's it's a
lock most at a time and it feels like it
- even in horde mode it feels pretty
good so witcher 3 last game i want to
mention oh it will be one of the best
looking games on the console now let me
ask you this question dealing reference
2 which would be specifically do you
think now that it's coming out right now
their reports are unpatch you know at 60
frames do you think they're gonna
maintain the 60 or do you think they'll
do it or give us the option as far as I
perform its modes and stuff like that
which is infinitely moved those hatrocks
ones batched yeah witcher 3 they tested
which are three unpatch so they went out
and got a disc version then they
unplugged the Xbox from the internet
they put it in the Excel automatically
ramped the firm rate up because the
launch version was no cat frame rewrite
do this right City skylines is now 60
frames spintires but runners now a lock
60 frames a lot of games do this and
it's inherit it's automatic so witcher 3
benefited it did 60 frames and combats
but of course as i've said several times
in the past in this city you've got
geometry complexity you've got a lot of
AI simulation things like that the cpu
becomes a bottleneck the framerate does
fall to around 40 45 frames per second
so we know it's possible to at least hit
60
while you're out in a while doing side
missions where a lot of people spend
their time would you I would love for
that to be a patch a part of the patch
60 frames per second which are three it
is not a GPU problem they could optimize
keep in mind the numbers before them
which are unoptimized numbers right they
just threw the game in the game had no
clue the X was even being made when it
was made
it just works and that's just that
natural yeah performance of the X doing
it I think lots more man I think we
could get that but I think CD Projekt
RED are afraid of people saying all the
game runs like trash just like they did
with Gears fanboys are to blame if we
don't you know ultimately because you're
gonna see flavors ugly you know we got
to see we got it would be interesting to
see what happens when you when the
official patch does compile but it is
impressive what is being done now so
let's get into these topics for the
round table got my man Lord addict up
and uh somebody's respawning right
what's going on respawn out here
no one's technically respawn but a
company called respawn Gaga so EA for
some reason you know could someone tell
me did you date that respawn was worth
four hundred million dollars like yeah
based on based on the price getting
jacked up but uh what is it Chinese
company I would hit I mean it's probably
illegal as hell but I'll be like you
know say like six hundred mill with
slide you a million a hundred million we
know EA go match you know like my thing
is like I just don't
it got bought for 400 million by EA do
you guys think that they bought that
because they want to keep that uh keep
that brand or do you guys think they
bought that because they don't want the
competition getting that brand miss good
question let's get it was good dealing
on this let's get as a feedback I've
talked so much already
um there's a lot of potential there's a
lot of potential there with respawn
anyone can see that titanfall came out
it sold 10 million plus titanfall 2
uh just reviewed extremely well you got
some 9.7 fives they know they've got
great a talent there and they're working
with Source engine you know they're
they're working at otech and in doing
their thing and they've just come out
with a phenom you know a lot on their
own they were an independent company and
they did what they did
EA CSIS and they know they can use that
team for other IPs and other projects
titanfall to EA this is all EA fault by
the way the tide fall to didn't do what
they wanted they competed with
themselves Duty gonna push it back and
just dominate we win at one of the
dumbest release dates Mark's like the
original one it would have dominated
mm-hmm no it would have did better than
what it actually did I think actually
there's gonna be uptake since uh you
know I feel that this X is given a
Gamestop of resurgence a lot of people's
gonna go and pick the game up you know
for $12 $9 whatever you can get it for
and you know to see the enhancements of
it to actually see the game in its good
form 1x so I'm pretty sure there's gonna
go back up quick question do you guys
think that um titanfall is a holiday
game if it's not competing with
battlefield mmm springtime summer game
yes
yeah I agree but I was just saying do
you think of battlefield wasn't there
and it just competed you know came out
enough time to breathe from Call of Duty
do you think it would have had a better
so it would have done better absolutely
it would have done better it just say
just again but battlefield the name
alone just crushed it it was a good
battle that's what hurt is I've never
been touched before like similar to call
a duty infinite jetpacks or whatever it
was called I agree and ultimately the
first titanfall you know Denny releasing
like a March like almost like a spring
kind of a window always felt like that
was a good place for it so this way it's
away from everything again chance to
breathe you away from the whole November
holiday card and
the other game to get tend to get packed
in at a holiday season so yeah I think
it would've been smarter to kind of push
it back to that next year so I take your
question yeah that was definitely close
down another studio all right makes you
worry about this because they they're
good at acquiring studios and closing
them but this rule is a different type
of be stiffer with more visceral more
single-player type games like the dead
space of stuff that's what they were
making so respawn I feel like respawns
put better quality out there than visual
studios was though that's why I think
they let this studio go to acquire this
studio you know um this idea was looking
at it and you know in their space it's
not apples and oranges they're looking
at him for exactly who they are who
performs well in this area and who they
should back money behind if I'm back
their money behind even one of those
Studios is actually gonna be respawned
it's not going to be visceral so pick up
respawn you're looking at the founders
of Infinity Ward exactly Modern Warfare
so it's one of those things like any and
they lean into what EA is leading into
now like you date they're not moving
away from these single-player games that
they can't monetize continuously they
already have a winning formula and what
titanfall does they know they have the
talent to to create other IP that can
lean into that monetization thing so
they I mean they're perfect they're
perfect again we don't know maybe in a
couple of months they shut so I think it
was a little lag brothers my Ben I was
just gonna say it's worth noting the
visceral employees they they didn't just
get fired and go home right these guys
got absorbed into other a studio still
you still see those guys Justin
the studio's no point in until at
explore next question is as far as on
the whole new Craig thing I think that
it's kind of funny because
philosophically Vincent pellet is
against that like they were so if you
remember during time I think you I don't
think he's gonna stay with the company
we're gonna see because that that's a
key thing for them they're also about
like not splitting up the playerbase
and stuff like that with the DLC pack
because I believe in time for to all the
DLC was kind of the map packs were kind
of free so it's gonna be interesting now
them seeing if they gonna bump heads
with EA and the execs I've guessed well
because we know EA trying to get the new
craze on you know I feel like they
trying to get you some water out front
out here you see a lot of these you know
there's this revenue that's out there to
be taken so it's funnies gonna see
what's gonna happen with Titan look law
Cognito
400 million dictates Luke rates with me
in a box made up a good questionnaire D
take Microsoft [ __ ] but try to buy them
no no after putting our platform game it
would have gotten the same they got with
Tomb Raider like after if they had
bought them immediately after time for
one I would have understood at the time
for to hmm no cuz you're gonna get
across the board saying that you're
taking away another multi-platform game
put it on a court on cold concrete
wasn't talking about you talking about I
[Music]
don't think the company Microsoft look
at actually Microsoft's first company
they should look at is the cuphead
makers that's the first company do you
think that space being exclusive could
have had an impact you know something
yes but fitting into what filling these
guys is talking about as far as
single-player and I'm pretty sure they
trying to get all the single-player
experience over the game pass to make
game pass super viable like you know the
same way they put in episodes of hitman
on it um I don't I don't think they fit
unless they're gonna make them adjust a
game past exclusive
company so I really don't think so it
just doesn't fit the same way that
Microsoft brought rear that didn't make
any sense Kinect games the reason they
bought rare is because they were trying
to launch the 363 Ferreira game yeah me
ultimately I mean if the opportunity is
there I always want my himself to
purchase studios you know that's that's
a fact but you know in reference to the
whole you know respawn thing which
sovereign is answering you know is one
of those things I'm talking because you
know it was this was under their
umbrella initially with titanfall one
you know I'm kind of set that it kind of
went multi-platinum one in a now so you
would see what happened with the results
of it so um you know my main concern is
hopefully that they don't get swept
under the rug in the you know the whole
EA umbrella and you know I wonder maybe
if the act that asking price was a
little bit too rich for Microsoft's
blood I mean obviously you had that
Korean company it was thankfully so it
was probably to reach for EA's blood but
if they didn't do it they were gonna
lose the company yeah
so we see what happens but ultimately
you know I'm not about Studios closing
so I like the fact that they will
continue on and we'll see what happens
with the future of titanfall 3 so
everyone's got done with a respawn we're
going to move on and speaking of our
friends at EA again it just made a
comment our good friend Andrew Wilson's
fan of the show he meta meta III me and
Lord addict and he actually made a
comment he made some comments to UM
Bloomberg and references you know to
sports games as a service and they
saying that they're looking to explain
that globally they kind of said that in
Korea and China they have their core
sports games like FIFO you know regular
updates and they provide like cold drops
every four years instead of an annual
release kind of a deal so I wanted to
bring this to the round table with the
Lords you know what do we feel about the
potential of sports games as a service
and is this the future that's something
that we want a far as far as the
subscription model so anybody can jump
in on this I think from the decline in
the sports games now everybody wants to
say that the sports games is boosted
from media I can't tell you in the last
time
brought a mat and I did try that long
yard episode crap that they got there
and I liked it I thought it was pretty
good um but when I purchase I'm a turn
for it now um the 2k I like the little
neighborhood thing when I purchase or 2k
for it no but when I buy a subscription
service since that there sports titles
that allows me to play all those games
at a cheap price like how EA does with
their EA access yes of course I'll be
down for that so I can touch out my
leisure I don't feel like I have to be
locked into a game so I think it's a
great thing I think games as a service
is a great thing in general this loss
soft because he's my resident sports guy
every now and then we used to vile you
know those the MLB games and stuff like
that so this curious about your
perspective on this loss what do you
feel what's the answer they need to go
everybody who makes a sports game on any
console should go this route I don't
it's been four years since I purchased
an MLB the show game which I used to
purchase on a yearly basis and it you
know these guys have eight months to
turn over a game every single year and
11 cycles are short it's it's admirable
the amount of improvements they make to
these games in a short amount of time
but I still don't think it's worth a $60
upgrade every single year on unless
you're a person that's deep into playing
like the season mode and the the
franchise mode and stuff you're not
gonna see the improvements right off the
bat like you really have to play day in
and day out to see oh they added this
animation all they added this like it's
a tough sell you know you create a base
game every couple of what four years for
you know three four years maybe five
years and you just expand on that every
year give me a thirty dollar upgrade
pack with new rosters some new
animations stuff like that in a $30 for
even $40 something that is not not
trying to sell to me as a full $60 game
and I'd be in every single year it
doesn't make any sense to me um it
really doesn't and the thing is as long
as we keep supporting it no two cases
in the top of the charts every single
year the show sells well every single
year so I mean it's gonna continue to
happen but they definitely need to get
away from that because to the best of my
knowledge EA has been doing this same
thing with that MBA live it seems like
every week they are giving you updates
which is actually physically changing
the players so like if it's a player
gets a haircut or grows a beard or
something like that they are actually
implementing that in the game on this is
the first game that they've had in a
couple of years it's quality enough that
people are sticking with international
acclaim with it so this is the perfect
testbed for them where they get they
gonna say okay we're gonna follow this
model and see how it works for this game
and that's fantastic me as a big
baseball head I would love things like
that well you see a guy get a different
haircut middle of the season know the
roster update does that's fantastic that
would be great um and in terms of what
you said about the entire games as a
service in terms of having entire
backlogs yeah absolutely that would be
fantastic just to be able to access MVP
2005 I was just about to ask you that I
see that because that's considered one
of like one of the you know marquee
baseball games of all time as well as
right if what is it uh 2k5 which one
which one was the ESPN one before Madden
took the license officially okay yeah
and those were those two engines right
there are considered respectively the
greatest sports engines of their you
know of their sport so I'd imagine if
those had iterative updates you know and
and roster change stuff like that would
that be something you'd be willing to
play subscription model for absolutely
you know when once Phil made it clear
that he was they weren't gonna go back
into their baseball license at least not
anytime soon so yeah well EA access
bring over a version of MVP 2005 if you
look at the PC the PC following in that
game every single year you have people
enthusiasts who make roster updates for
that game to play in engine on the PC I
mean and these people are the detail and
the work that they put into these roster
updates for a game that came out
in 2005 it's crazy but there goes a
passion for that game in that engine
right putting it on the console
especially for a console that doesn't
have a baseball game aside from you know
RBI whatever and I don't think that
doesn't count you know it would be
fantastic it would be fantastic I think
sports games need to go that route
regardless they just do let's get a
let's get our uh schedule on non sports
guy Lord addict see what his position is
I'm curious I'm not a sports guy pass
would you be would you do you just think
the practice in itself as far as like
annual annualized sports games now
possibly change into this is it
something that you would be you know
you'd be approved you would approve it I
just leave me that [ __ ] for free and
that still wasn't downloaded understand
the question is what practice didn't
offer I mean they do I mean look at Call
of Duty they they utilize a bunch of
different [ __ ] every year so I mean the
fact that sports do it doesn't surprise
me I think maybe they should go towards
like you know a killer instinct mode
where you know at seasons maybe I don't
know like I don't do sports like I
couldn't really tell you what's a good
way to do it what's a bad way to do it
pretty much you're not a postal you're
not opposed to them actually changing
this model so I mean you know what I am
opposed for I feel like ei shouldn't
waste a conference every year on sports
but that's just look dealer what do you
feel about these those what's game is
this a mistake not in sports games
myself Fight Night see trash it doesn't
work well on a controller
and get fight night back in there it's a
much better time on a controller so
sports games it depends on what to try
to charge every month if it's five bucks
ten bucks a month maximum you know what
are they trying to charge that's the
question right to sports games a year
than ten bucks a month maybe isn't a bad
deal because you're getting exactly what
you pay for it throughout the year well
if you just buy Madden you know I don't
know then it's like hey oh well it's
nice that I got a shiny your helmet
through this update you know mostly for
now which is basically all they do is
force games you know I do I do want to
say that if they start charging for you
know stuff like that do you guys think
that you know they're they're
microtransactions continues Iron Man he
put some serious money on oath to the
team does that stuff 2k with the VC crap
these guys eat crazy industries so yeah
I think Tyler for powering those
microtransaction keeping the light or
did that 42% he's not keeping the lights
on he's putting BMWs and all the
executives I'm gonna go put fight night
on on my kind of funny all your games do
look better man you notice that that 16
times texture filtering instantly see
the cracks and stuff in the ground you
never saw before detail on the ground
The Witcher 3
this helps which are a lot Plus that
games already dynamic resolution so you
get a straight 1080p with a better
texture feel during this stuff it looks
really good state of decay doesn't run
like trash anymore pretty bad you've
been on the X
I mean ocean guy spin the camera around
a few times load the world into RAM and
once it does that it's pretty decent man
I think the worst part about stated okay
just like that physics like the weird
physics that game got like you'd be
driving like 15 you'll hit a rock into
two flips you gotta keep it exciting man
so state okay one absolutely the best
Sonic game of all time - phenomenal man
the finishing of this uh eh uh because I
don't wanna bore dealer an addict to
death oh I would the moment you know you
suffer you do take one for the king
right now appreciate it that's relative
yeah I would solve on this one thousand
you know I think this is something I
need to happen you know it was long
overdue
you know the updates were just too
incremental as far as the dev cycle and
I'm always a fan of being like being
able to miss something right like I saw
I always had that problem with
annualized franchise it's like oh how
much dev time how much change can you
really make in these games are becoming
more expensive so it's like you know
this is something I would definitely
look forward to but I do agree with deal
in a sense that you know they have to be
mindful of what this price is gonna be
because it is charge of something like
you know ten fifteen dollars a month I
don't know you know now EA is in the
right position because they've kind of
tested this whole service thing out with
EA access right they were the first to
kind of like pioneer that whole movement
so it'll be interesting to see when this
goes in into effect I know Korea and
those markets already do it but yeah I
wouldn't mind taking about two three
years off a madam make a premium tier
yeah cuz it makes sense the service and
in the subscriber numbers from not only
to make it look better for their
investors but it just makes sense to
make this part of EA access somehow
absolute sports pass you know some it's
it's eight bucks a month instead of Fox
I'm completely read my mind and I think
that's my that's my guess that's my
guess what I think they going because
again ain't were the first to pioneer
that good good in it I think a good way
to probably do would be you know you
it's like sling TV you know you can like
buy your packages it's like you know if
you want this this this game you you
know it's like you bring up the app and
you just click what games you actually
play because some people
subscribe to the service as I don't care
about FIFA like I don't want to pay for
a whole service for FIFA there's no joke
and a lot of people like let's be honest
I mean for us sports guys a lot of it
Lord King and tell you like we just want
the next year because our man got traded
to another team let's just keep it a
buck like that that's really why a lot
of reason why we're doing it so if
you're giving us these incremental
patches and updates and putting the
rosters on correctly everyone's got the
correct hairstyle trust me people with
subscribing to that you know the key is
just that price run range
and like I said if they came up with
something like deal was saying almost
like a EA access sports tier I'm in I
think they should do is do like a
premium EA access to where all the games
that are released are free and EA access
for let's say you know the 1099 or
whatever the price Netflix is a month
and you get to play every all that stuff
that they release throughout the year
for that for the premium price I'm down
for that I paid it $2.99 I don't really
care because I got to pick up that need
for speed and I know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna play the need for speed I'm
gonna get halfway in the middle of it
and I'm gonna get this interested and go
play something else
but if if I had as you know the
subscription I can play all these stuff
that comes out every other month
you know EA puts out a game every other
month and I'll be down for that but they
get more revenue from that service go to
check I don't care what virtue hairstyle
for true men guys so let's see we'll see
what happens they would do something
like that all their games a year it'd be
something like $20 a month to be honest
with you the day they were what at least
you know at least a portion of that
money from one game was like one-third
the money they would have potentially
got from you you're just gonna you know
you're probably not even gonna play the
whole game but most people are probably
gonna beat it in the first week and
they're gonna unsubscribe you know and
they just paid 20
the point that's a good point today
something likes things think about us
for sure well yeah the way they could do
it is I think what's that WWE Network
like uh my friend he subscribed to that
night first you had to subscribe for six
months there's like a contract like you
had to so I guess they could go down
that direction they release a new game
like the seventh month or is the
Ultimate Edition car packed like yeah
yes six months of car packs and it's all
trucks ridiculous for six months we're
gonna move on no King the Beast has
released let's talk about it baby
alright so in the aftermath of Xbox one
eggs hitting these streets now a lot of
the Lord's got a chance to go to e3 yeah
and you know we went to e3 trust me
these games did not look like this when
we touch sacks okay so now that we got a
chance to get the beast inside you know
these patches are really doing work and
it's living up to its expectations of
far exceeding what you know Phil Spencer
said
my question is to everyone what happens
now how does the rhetoric change what
happens with Sony how do they scramble
do they look at the numbers do they see
things where do we go as a gaming group
conglomerate actually how do we move
forward and where do we go where do we
see it going once this piece is out on
the streets which is changing our old
games and new games to look better and
run better this is first time this has
ever happened so I'm gonna know where do
we see this going I mean you know what I
can see going
I see those pros going
GameStop to buy the this is a going I
mean okay so I'll let you jump it that's
the yuffie i don't want to jump in on
this too
i just i think they're gonna lean into
what you know whatever their messaging
has been till now they're gonna keep
leaning into the game stuff so we have
the games they don't have the games and
it's gonna keep saying that and ads you
know and it's gonna work for a lot of
people be perfectly honest aren't ups
they don't really care about those those
those upgrades and whatnot we're we're
different like we this is what always I
was gonna ask you this because it is
kind of bleeds into something I was
gonna ask in reference to this topic
which is what's that joy King would I
have like I'm restoring the feeling a
lot of this is just what I've seen as a
perception at launch of the launch week
of DX is that it's almost like a
feel-good feeling almost like a dare we
say the honeymoon phase where it's like
I've seen a lot of people who are on the
fence or extremely skeptical you know
they're seeing what's going on is seeing
the digital foundry reports and now
doing am i saying that this is you don't
represents the majority you know this is
probably a small vacuum you know but at
the same time you know there is a sense
that okay this is the right one right
this is the system that we you should
have got you know kind of deal so yeah I
think that kind of plays into this whole
thing with Sony as far as them trying
maybe trying to be more aggressive you
know what they have PSX come in and
stuff like that like what do you think
that whole that whole vibe plays into
this floor so I mean absolutely I think
they they finally if it finally feels to
the people who are big so many
supporters that oh this is a real this
is real competition now this is a this
is a console that they have to they have
to worry about in that regard because if
you're looking at PlayStation not
releasing a new console let's say in two
years right so they have to deal with
two years of digital foundry breakdowns
saying that's our friend experts better
pixels in there so beautiful finish
voice
five years two years week in week out
hearing about how the most powerful
version of your system still can't
compare to the ex is is not gonna sit
well with them so again that's why I
said they're gonna lean into the game
stuff right I already heard that they're
rumors at PS X they're gonna be
announcing a new Devil May Cry and a new
soul calibur there which of both games
that are multi-platform and we'll
probably look better on X but the fact
that they have it on their stage he does
have a better version on the egg
completely hearts market II he did
really done right right I mean we the
firm that's destiny so late that their
version was coming up you know exactly
so they're gonna keep leaning into the
game stuff and if I were them I would
because they have a lot of single-player
stuff they have a lot of stuff that's
only for them as of now we know that
Phil said they're doubling down on then
and I expect to hear more of that in
2018 but as of now we don't have
quote-unquote we don't have anything
well you know shout out to the saltiest
game about for eight that's my dude
let's get more deal in here man on
aftermath of the xbox one next much
going on in each streets what do you
feel it's happening you know I feel as
the Sony better change the slogan the
best place to play because I know it's
not it's not true anymore
Sony a bit you know they've had
phenomenal third-party support we all
know this it's been they're saving grace
gonna put it that way they actually had
a very similar amount of first party
titles this year to Microsoft but it's
all third party stuff propping them up
you know hell-blade and all this other
stuff and that's great but people get it
mixed they are not investing more into
games of Microsoft they just aren't and
and the fact that they have the same
amount of first party stuff is kind of
proof to that so we'll have to see what
they do in the future of Microsoft tree
announcing that hey we're reinvesting a
billion dollars into games this is the
second time they said this in that eight
months the media finally picked up on it
you know this is good news I don't think
there's anything hanging on my neighbors
decide that
you know it's time to being on the wall
with a hammer PlayStation fanboys
telling you shut up yeah it's uh it's
pretty ridiculous so with the x-man
you're just gonna see easily the best
third party there is there's no
accidentally having the best version on
PlayStation right now you know it's kind
of funny because half a teraflop was
into the world before you had 902 1080
now you literally have four more million
pixels on the X kind of just on games
that they've just poured it in a few
days you know these are some of these at
first party or marketing deal games -
with Sony they're still getting
destroyed you know you got to keep in
mind that's a lot of extra headway there
and they're really they're able to use
it and if they don't or if they have a
gain disparity or if they begin it's
worse then that's all on the developer
there's absolutely no reason every title
shouldn't completely be better than
every single way on the X absolute let's
only have to deal with that for like you
said another couple years how are they
gonna do it we don't know but change
that change the slogan that's for sure
deal it's kind of interesting because we
talked about this on ILP before and you
know I think that one thing that
Microsoft's not getting enough credit
and when a handless is that they gave
that reveal of the X digital foundry and
I thought that was genius because they
we're basically the voices of generation
as far as the comparison and when people
go to see as far as resolution gate and
all these things so you give it to your
biggest critic but isn't a product but
it also shows now from this point moving
forward when those comparison videos
come out I mean let's make no mistake
did rule foundry is eating off of this
what this is ultimately benefiting
Microsoft almost any terms of free
market allies they know digital foundry
say well you know it's only 5 million
more pixels
I utilize that performance performance
and this is a lot of extra you know kind
of headway here on games and don't even
have 4k texture assets like shadow war
and stuff like that so you show that you
saw the shadow or video that was in the
world yeah this is gonna be commonplace
over the next few years more games are
gonna do this so turn on absolutely
extend your allies that's exactly what
they did with the review units people
were mad cuz certain people man Kiwi
Xbox which I'm so glad you said that
dealer I am so glad you see if your
strategy guys you gotta turn you got to
advertising out there turn your critics
into your allies thank you my man
Lord addict where we at with this what's
the aftermath like based on what you
feeling not at the exes I know you don't
got one just yet but based on the
temperature in these streets like what
do you what are you feeling what's going
on what attic what's not sleeping you
know honestly just like it's really good
to see you know I know some people are
mentioning it maybe honeymoon phase but
at the end of the day I mean just seeing
what the ex is capable of and instead
just going into your entire life XY they
put Z's or the jet what's going on with
the library really pop some ambien or
something good kid goes well sleep in
the whole chat whenever it happens it's
hilarious alright let it go it really
does more for because I can definitely
see you know the tire change in parts of
comparisons as far as all that good
stuff but what I wanted to now ask next
and reference to the launch of the beast
is not at these games out and everyone's
testing them and playing them let's know
a lordy like what what's your top three
games right now so I sure it's in you
know what I mean like as far as the X is
like what's the top 3 I was really
impressed you whether death or
first quality like I would say I would
say and this kind of feeds into what
some reviewers are saying to people
saying they're not impressed
well you're not impressed with PC gaming
if you're playing gears award you're not
impressed
I have that game on pc i played the
ultra settings that's pretty much high
off your setting hybrid right there that
is pc visuals and in playing that and
seen at 60 frames was one of the one of
the one of the points where you realized
that okay this is different this is
next-level and not only does it benefit
4k owners or whatever TV you have 1080p
guys get this cuz you get all you know
it's awesome so gears is definitely
something you got to see by the way
people messaging me about that the
toggle for the framerate performance
mode is not available in game on gears
so you have to do that in the main menu
yet push start where you're at the main
menu and going to enhance the visuals or
whatever and do it there so here's is
definitely one so the battlefront 2 is
next level 60 frames there's so many
yeah that's the screen has things about
it they'll blow your mind
Wolfenstein no I cheat a little bit but
you gotta check those games out yeah Wow
absolutely amazing and I'm glad you made
that planning reference to super
sampling shadow Megaman in the chat
because um you know there's a lot of
people that actually upset with
Microsoft because they don't feel that
they've done a good enough job of really
promoting it as far we have said yeah
you still get benefits over 1080p but
there's something to be said about the
visual shout out to my man John liniment
from digital foundry he had something up
with a Wolfenstein ensuring it ain't any
piece super sampling almost like a
before and after and I'm seeing a lot of
people who are posting you know pictures
and I'm like that looks you know what
you know a 4k any like no bro this is
not for gate isn't my 1080p TV with
super sampling so that's something that
really is not being stressed enough that
you was denied and I talked to Phil
Spencer I was on a party with him I told
him that this is this is something I'm
getting in my comment section
people saying I have 1080p TV this is
not going to benefit me it's a developer
by developer basis obviously with gears
you get 60 frames I told him that
somehow you got to portray that these
games are getting settings boost
as well so - sir you're getting much
higher quality settings gears are
getting all the bells and whistles
wolfenstein you're getting but I think a
better setting or - but also I've always
said that with Xbox guys this upgrade is
a little more valuable because you've
been playing some games at 720p thank
you know you're getting minimum double
you know two million pixels instead of
what seven to nine hundred thousand
pixels and that's gonna bring out the
detail that's already there so it's
gonna look like some graphics settings
have been added when they in fact
haven't and you know that like I said
and then you upgrade to a 4k TV and you
get another bump and then developers
going to start figuring out hey let's
add some more modes let's play around on
top of the things what are you doing so
you know it's a good value no matter how
you want to cut it yeah absolutely I
mean definitely you being against some
more great points in fact you know
people are not realizing that with the s
a lot of these games you know were
weren't hitting 1080p you know a lot of
Mo 7:29 I'm not on GPU no sub you know
you're dancing resolution so just off of
that alone without even the super
sampling they're getting the way the
games were supposed to be intended but
none for me going let's get a soft and
Lord King in or as far as the your
rankings as far as what you've touched
and you know solve what what do you feel
like well she tapped three right now as
far as showcasing I think three is too
few yeah I bet I mean I started out you
know let's do this let's do top three
and then one of the local sleep my top
three like dealer said gears
once in gears in high performance mode
with 60 frames per second I think any
one of these X Games once you put on the
60 frames per second and you have either
high resists high res textures or just
straight 4k or getting close to 4k
dynamic resolution those are the ones
that are the biggest jump that you
really see like wow like this is a big
jump so for me for K Gears of War is
it's a revelation yeah
rise of the Tomb Raider absolutely
insane instead on this morning - um but
again the performance more like the the
true 4k mode is nice it's very shiny but
when you put on the high quality mode
with the 60 frames per second that is
absolutely the way that game is meant to
be played and you get those 4k assets
and every mode in that game - and that's
the thing the for asus is so huge so
huge because they just the game pops
that much more um and then it has to be
a hitman looks fantastic to me but yours
I don't even own Forza off the demo
alone for this for the Cygnus was really
sick and so asked beyond beyond those
top three Halo 5 looks like yeah it's
just it runs perfectly now like and it
looks insane so it is the best kind of
overall use of the power of the X and
the fact that it can be applied in so
many different ways the game runs
beautifully you say what you want about
the game proper but especially what you
know but the game is beautiful on that
hit man that hit man oh my god in
high-performance mobile 65 section where
I didn't expect that that one surprised
me I think it was told me to download
was it you I was just like blown away
but yeah
hey that's a good one that was your
honorable mention oh no oh yeah that's
definitely hitman was there something
else really caught my apps and
Assassin's Creed there are things in
that game there moments um when the sun
is shining in the middle of the desert
the game is beautiful as it is but
there's certain moments that really take
you back um that game is fantastic
um one game that is a little
disappointment to me mafia 3 mafia 3 has
HDR and Jorge's appointment Leon - good
really mama
the lighting engine in the game was
always screwed and I was hoping that
with HDR enhancements it's just not it
looks soupy to me like that it just
doesn't it doesn't work I was hoping
that the DLC stuff might help with all
the added like seasonpass stuff but I
was thinking that game you could access
that stuff outside of
game the main game and maybe they had
worked on it separately from the main
game but they did it's all accessible
within the main game so it's all the
same engine all the same lighting and
not great not great lord King give me
those top three out of everything right
now but to my top to these first party
games
um it's gears mm you can't unsee guess
once you see it it's like this is where
you know like if my kids were in the
house when I put it on I put gears on
and they realized that it was something
different going on on the TV my son was
like daddy what happened it looks it
looks incredible what's going on I said
do this so that I and I fought with this
because really was halo 5 was my first
but it's that HDR on there gears
halo 5 and second I'm so happy because I
was a real fan of Halo 5 when people's
dog and it or whatever I love this story
I love the multiplayer whatever it's a
beautiful game and plays beautiful 343
doesn't get enough credit the story
actually was engrossed into me I loved
it
so I'm gonna play it again and if
anybody didn't play it hey go get the
game it's cheap it's cheap right now I'm
here I'll play also Forza I was not
buying this game all right
I've played it at e3 I won't wait
actually
let's give a not let's not give a
shout-out to the TVs at e3 that would
display honestly I really don't think it
was the TV's I really optimized Asian
they weren't ready I don't think the
patches are out at e3 they were they
they were I really don't think they were
ready because the floor etiquette that
attest it is these games weren't moving
well he didn't he doesn't see it um and
I can't wait to he does see it but they
weren't moving at 60 frames per second
was they attic I mean did you see it
only only when I was moving at 60 frames
was the Forza but it just it looked good
but it didn't do what it's doing now was
it wowing like yeah yeah a something to
be said like I said I don't know if
their 4k game was not right if they if
the you know but they had Samsung's
though oh it just looked very average
you you could like you could have lied
to me and said I was telling people I
was like where's the 4k like I just
didn't for whatever reason I don't know
again it was a configuration setting
picture setting or whatever or like was
it alright we saw we saw all this other
stuff regardless to what III I walked
away from it and well i'ma pick up
another system I felt it was just like a
pro to be honest with you I was just
like oh just like the pro whatever I'm
getting anyway and whenever they make
games to take advantage of it I'll be
down with brother when you put it on
everything is fantastic everything is
literally fantastic no matter what
display that you got you can run these
things how you gonna trust me listen I
don't get it Mick will offer this my
stuff for the ones that I so shout out
to those but then my honorable mentions
has to go to Assassin's Creed because
that's the only game that I got that was
new smart you're smart guy here
yeah happy that you were you work on a
t3 you were surrounded by people you
kind of you know it wasn't really an
environment and a lot of that that's
coming to play like people try psvr I
went out in about and they're like oh
man it was horrible but then they get a
home in their own environment and and
it's different to them you learn I'm
saying so it got something to do with
maybe now they gave us drinks though
they gave us drink shadow or if you want
to stare it like I guess there's more
EULA Sardar uh cape or a rock or stone
thirty minutes longer than the earth
should shadow or absolutely has some
most insane insane textures you've ever
seen in your life you want to know what
that's like
shadow orders a game gigabyte patch
things real quick Lord dealer shout to
loss drink of all in the chat he wants
to ask you a question as far as what are
the two latest settings on high frame
rate if you know uh honestly don't know
I do know the 4k textures go through all
the modes so you get 4k assets in that
mode that's the mode I'm playing it on
and keep in mind I'm going back between
all three and I think that mode looks
the best overall it looks great in terms
of visuals but the fluidity the frame
rate is absolutely locked so far and
interview so well so it just you know I
don't know if you played it yet but once
you do you won't care it looks
absolutely astonishing yeah and shout
out to your point with the um shadow
would I think Microsoft actually he's
dr. ball with one thing there's a mode
as far as the 4k cinematic texture pack
that they're not telling people was
available it's 21 to be fair though they
did the same thing on the PSN store it's
a thing in the DLC store the same thing
on Steam and the Microsoft Store it's a
separate download in the in the store
for that game you gotta download these
cinematic practices it's just
interesting dealer why they won't
they're not really promoting it as
something available it's almost I don't
know I don't feel like it's being
publicized yes I don't see where they
had with this intelligent download is
coming into play when
the hard drive I could tell you one game
already that's using Assassin's Creed my
origin okay so when you boot that game
up if you noticed it asks you what and
keep in mind intelligent deliveries
designed as such so it doesn't give you
unnecessary things right right English
you're gonna be speaking English it's
not gonna give you the Spanish
voiceovers an audio is a massive part of
these file sizes so they find that you I
hear everything in English but some guy
across the world is hearing every single
part of that game in Chinese or whatever
right right they got all those voice
actors for each language all of that so
estas to be dora jhin's when you boot it
up it says you want english whatever do
you notice the other languages have a
cloud next to them you actually have to
download those oh okay
and that's why that game is forty four
gigabytes with the next patch these
patches are not as big as some people
are saying they are I've got tons of
games at around 50 gigabytes with an X
patch only a few games at 100 gigabytes
even Tomb Raider with 4k pack 30
gigabyte now low but it's still only 50
something gigabytes some chicken game
stop was selling people Exodus when I
went and picked mine up and she was
telling people that call duty was 70
gigabytes and every game with the acts
as a hundred gigabytes it's a hundred
and seventy gigabytes on the X and this
is a Gamestop employee Norse hard drives
you know there's a lot of misinformation
out there these games are not nearly as
big as you think they are there's a few
hundred gigabyte plus games but that's
in yeah I got 19 terabytes as I was
afraid it was having a nice on a 12
terabyte and remember I had a six inside
my house so they stack so I was like oh
and then also they took away a terabyte
when it gave me a system because
remember my SI had the Gears of War
system and add the two terabyte I still
come around I sold mine Amazon's
oh I wanna shout out definitely wolf
astons on that list man did that this
morning completely blown away that
machinegames man that game looking
fantastic and to be honest with you I
wasn't that impressed
until he gets out and spoiler alert
until he gets out of the wheelchair
frames kicks it cuz I was like a first
me always looks pretty looks nice you
know I wasn't like I was disgusted with
it you know just like okay this looks
nice when he gets out and you're moving
around I was like wow this is insane
the wolf is through so that's on the
list you gotta throw in Halo it don't
know in Halo it's a completely new game
it that the for cake it just really
breathe completely new life into the
title you know the resolution it's just
it's really it's really sweet specially
multi players well you gotta jump in
that um one of my third list Ivan so
non-disclosures my list is coming
complete cuz I haven't touched on shadow
voice yet that's what my list I still
have to touch that but um yeah man it's
gears hey we we gotta give a shout out
to all the fanboys over the past year
that was completely wrong about
everything
$800 $700 it does have 4k support
developers are supporting it they're not
doing parody they're not just not
supporting it because the pro and the
buspar is out front
they're not doing any of this crap you
say you know that it just really makes
me think they some dumb [ __ ] they do now
this out oh it's underwhelming so my own
za i 7o GT x 1080 right first thing I
thinking when I'm playing Wolfenstein I
boot this game up or like this PC
quality experience this is what it's
like to game on a game PC all of Duty
Battlefront all of these games Gears of
War at 60 frames this is a PC quality
experience in many ways it's undeniable
and that's the thing that and that's
what they're trying to kind of throw
into the rug like when you make when
they're making these comparison videos
now this yet making XPS for pro and PC
comparisons gained in PC isn't
necessarily worth the money like this is
this machine is astonishing for five
hundred dollars what is able to do they
want to downplay that at every turn
every turn and every mate they're down
place that right well let's let's be
honest let's keep it let's keep it all
the way on G I mean a lot of this you
know we're not gonna disrespect piscina
says that we know it something if you
have that ultimate rig yeah of course
it's gonna be the best place to play but
at the end of the day exactly
representing shout out to your guy
called Eastwood I saw your video dealer
as far as breaking now you know
comparison to getting building a final
exactly you know I'm saying as far as
really being being real about what you
can get for that value you cannot deny
the value of the X in the average
consumer Joe Blow comes home from work
you know they either don't have the
patience nor the intelligence no
disrespect to nobody to try to sit there
and piece together a rig like that
whereas you just buy a box plug in plain
good to go they're still what it's
showing it there's still value and it's
still benefiting it and you're still
getting these PC like high level
experiences so we can't deny it we just
we're just seeing a lot of it let's keep
it real like a lot of intimidation
people are intimidated any little
certain the governor hissing at the Xbox
no that's part of this whole family
thing I get it you know and right now
that X is up right now it's to be
expected but overall from what I see
it's been a lot of positive responses
and a lot of people you know give
bigging it up in saying giving it the
credit deserves especially in comparison
video in comparison to the Nace's
because i got to keep it on drew there
was some people that was saying oh you
know it's not necessarily warranted to
jump first I'm I don't I don't advocate
anyone going and living out started a
means now shout out to anchorman who got
his system for his price I was worried
in the beginning I thought
to finagle something to help him out but
he got him no hustle
you know after I got off my deals
I was looking towards him to help him
out because he expressed interest in
certain things so I said you know
definitely help him up
but lo and behold I saw the tweet I sort
of price brother you have that you an
ace
that's a trading trading so um I won't
advocate anybody you know going out
breaking a bank for it if you can't
afford it don't worry about it you know
do it when you can't afford it but I can
say this without a shadow of a doubt
when you boot up any old it game that
you have in your library digital if you
have a CD a physical copy trust me you
will see a difference on no matter what
display you display that you do not need
a 4k television all right
I thought Microsoft was it was BS really
honestly
yes big effort I'll be honest I'm with
you on that Lord King I will never talk
even if you don't look at the super
sampling and you know you don't look at
you know the 4k aspect it's like people
with 1080p TVs can definitely benefit
from this console because like it's like
I said games like Halo Wars to that
dropped drastically in frames regardless
you know before KTV or not those frames
ain't dropping mm-hmm yeah it's trust me
some of these games like unity need
stuff like that yeah so question I mean
just just to just look at the other side
of the coin have you guys experienced
anything that in terms of experience on
the console so far that isn't great the
greatest so hasn't been let me jump in
chronobreak know you get that you know
why I want you to all and situation oh
no no no - the cooler
you know this is where you had the
fidelity and I saw when I press and
where's the option to bump it up hdmi
cord that reaches from you go straight
the remedy King got the remedy feet-9
some change upstairs I don't see the
same jump I'm doing I'm doing the same
some cash eight hundred eight thousand
excuse me you know HD or whatever you
know no Olay but at the same time just
one of those things that that's what I
realized
where 1400 like forty hundred feet what
it was a viable yeah like this shutter
is on dealing all right give me some
because each other's off okay it's off
but on that television it has this thing
called HDR plus mode alright so but
alright
when I put on that hdr+ mode on that
game in particular hmm it's crazy it's
crazy
I think hdr+ mode is just coming sports
mode or or game mode if you want
watching HDR content or just adjust all
the settings in the TV it's like a
preset to get them right out of what
your TV can do yeah I'm against all of
that stuff I am a picture quality purist
so I yeah that's probably my only
negative experience honestly and to me
this is less if the game looks better
than how it was looking right listen I'm
not gonna disrespect the game though
you've got these high quality the UI for
me doesn't necessarily run that much
faster I don't really see you know what
game starts with me who's home what's
that that desert game that they had with
the little girl no the desert game the
record has a thing for record about is I
got so many games and I got an ex like I
forget the names but you can remember
the games me oh here we go
I don't need 400 plus okay so your point
is I still have these games so it's in
relevant
[Laughter]
Oh any little issues you've been having
as far as ohm you know I already any gay
maybe not even issues but let's just say
any game you may have any
inconsistencies with the X if
inconsistency or any game that maybe
didn't as prep impression as you thought
you might come into Crescent hmm
honestly man every game I booted up has
been substantially better pressed with
with everything I've seen my girl has
been playing a lot of slime rancher even
that game got you know an upgrade you
know it still looks like slime Ranger
because I'm saying right like he's
absolutely badges yes what always said
like probe yeah got patches but they
were quite unsubstantial you know you
got you know same 1080p mode maybe with
some better high resolution shadows
versus or a better a you know not only
you're gonna get more patches with the X
but they're gonna be more substantial
they're gonna have high res texture
packs are gonna do more you're getting
more options that's great
I just I'm not known as a pro owner I am
definitely more pleased with everything
I'm saying yeah absolutely over there
bro and I you know I haven't I don't
know man it's just a very good
experience some people are kind of
worried because the game might crash
once or twice what I can recommend it is
now the Xbox one X is using a 7200 rpm
Drive and the internal now which is a
lot faster that's why you're getting
load times that are in some cases move
that game to the internal drive it may
be more consistent it may not I'm glad
you said a few messages about that hey
my game crash is that normal yeah it
happen on the yes and and you know move
it to the internal see if it keeps
happening but it's not a common issue
apparently Oh Lord addict I know you are
pretty much like us again Roxas yeah but
um anything that you're seeing right now
that might impress you to make the jump
or anything future got the good fallout
an upgrade I like that I can play the
good fallout you know no dummy yeah I'm
kind of disappointed that they're going
to look at
you know the bad fallout let me ask this
question turn around say real quick um
what about the games that like I said
I'm not patched have you guys I tried
those out have you because I've done
some loading test like to where my
biggest offenders were like Tekken 7 and
Osceola XCOM 2 and these are unpatched
games and I actually do those on and I
was really impressed by the decreasing
load times also it I think that's
nothing that's not get enough credit is
no time to the actual screen mm you know
to the actual Start screen I'm seeing a
significant improvement in that so I
don't know if any of you guys have been
trying out any of the older games have
you guys seen any any differences throw
a Mad Max I did Mad Max and Mad Max is
one of those games it does take a while
to load up and and especially loading
into like the desert it's a lots of
linen actually like yeah it's pretty
fast and and the game is it just feels
substantially smoother than it did on
the S even um oh yeah that's pretty much
the only one that I've booted up that
doesn't have an enhancement in destiny
and all the people have X's they load in
first before the people that have a s
even before the NPC's are spawned in so
I'll be in the board all the way at the
chip and these guys spawn in and I just
start killing stuff when I see their
NPCs spawning I just start killing a
move before they get a chance to get
like the arms-dealer quest it is the
best when you have an X gonna spawn in
ahead of time
I mean it's been a it's been a fun time
so far with this x-man and really seeing
what everything's going on out there and
just see any improvements and definitely
it's been a great week obviously for
Microsoft in this regard so uh
you wrap this thing up soon as anyone's
got anything left to say on the beast
what deal my mind would be I would just
say have a have a good time enjoyed
these peace equality experiences on a
console for you know in many cases the
first time and it's only gonna get
better from these are just older games
that developers have dug out of some
boxes in the in the office right the old
code out they've decided hey we're gonna
patch this real quick put it up put a
day or two in and they're done and they
look this great so you know these games
you know especially marketing deal games
are going to look absolutely insane in
the future and look forward to more
console exclusive 4k texture packs
things like that now that they got this
this platform do you think it's really
vital that Microsoft secures as many
high you know rated games that they
possibly can for marketing just to make
money well I get that but you know like
I feel like being able to you know
promote with that because let's be
really games like destiny you know Call
of Duty we know these games are coming
out but you don't really hear them
talking about because they got Margaret
girls right right right right yeah I
mean still just came over the statement
you know the reinvestment into the you
know first party you know their own IP
so I mean it to me the way I look at it
now is like the the work on the hardware
in is done you know this thing is
successful and it's actually gonna bleed
into the poll question that will and
show off with but um you know it's one
of those things where he's got that
aspect done so now all you have to do
for 2018 is just keep bringing them
games just keep bringing them titles
keep showing the difference keep having
those exclude like Lord ela said those
exclusive titles on the platform you
know invest in that and showcase those
differences and maybe now you can start
to get that momentum and keep it you
know it's important to for for Microsoft
and third parties as well and I think
they're leaning this way they game on PC
they like for 60 frames better than 30
that's just a universal fact it's just
better amazing at an option on every
game that can possibly be an option on
imagine what games like angle six is
gonna look like on that X yeah
they're definitely being built with the
ex and mine mm-hmm no doubt so we got
the last thing was the new ILP poll this
week so now that the Beast has a vine
has Microsoft kept its word with the
Xbox 1x and restored the feeling the
choices will be a yes Phil kept his word
and Xbox is now heading back in the
right direction or B no this is just a
honeymoon phase and the games are still
like I gotta get my Sony dudes baguette
baby so I gotta give them day they would
even speak about not having games
literally didn't have pains for years I
mean uncharted the Nathan Jake
collection was your fall game for one
year or something like that you know
just facts though right I'm never wrong
nope you're right in the initial part of
the cycle yes Microsoft to have hazed
their worst year ever in terms of
exclusives yes we call it the audio
second T what it is it's over the
droughts over now you're playing the
same things we are all third party stuff
just like you touted about four years
you know jeez I'm actually pretty pretty
damn balanced but when I hear these
hypocrites talk about this stuff it's
annoying it's annoying it's all the
difference between three point six
million pixels and eight million
right now you can tell that difference
but nine hundred feet of 1080 you could
huh because of one year of bad
exclusives and you know I would even say
it was like you know if you look at it
like a whole lot worse than my Christine
that Sony me look at Sony's first party
the second party in the third party like
all it's like what did they drop this
year they drop that too they dropped
horizon and they drop sports like that's
all like we can't minimize the mean why
would Lana we're talking first party the
thing that they first was about second
party we're talking about the first part
is that they always criticize and
look Microsoft had a bad year everyone's
accepted this but you know there's part
people I think that's made the same
video 15 times I mean those people out
there they come out there and they say
Microsoft has never had exclusives but
I'm like they went more cuz I would
think first the second party I think you
threw out the generator or a very
similar amount me you can't argue that
not only that but most more of those
games are in the 80s or the 80s then
with Sony as well when it comes to their
first party stuff where Sony has you
know a couple must-haves which really
I'm trying to force that game for me
I'm Charter for is absolutely phenomenal
I've always said this big uncharted fan
and you know people say well tomb
raiders better and I'm like well okay
that's highly debatable and secondly
they have both over there so it doesn't
matter right you know really good high
quality experiences but you've got to at
least give props a lot of these guys are
both hypocrites and they can't even say
yes the ex is a good piece of kit the 4k
driving that makes it $100 price
difference is they come out I'll give
you that eco like life's legacy to come
but you don't still see though you know
whatever mountain there's a game come on
now I got blood-borne is not the best
game this came out this year Oh some
look somebody said the 4k blu-ray player
who you listen to
won't you fellows reviews and the
highest and 4k blu-ray players out there
have slightly better post-processing
that's it it's not listen to the fraud
you're listening to and I think I know
who it is and just look up stuff because
information is ubiquitous let's learn
together let me help you can't even
really debate what what console has
better exclusives because it's all
subjective you get out someone that
literally hates playing games by
themselves they don't like seeing player
games they were raised with the multi
mentality they might not like any game
Sony be dropped
I really really hate playing over there
because it feels like I'm gonna isolate
a bubble a lot of people do but you know
don't get me wrong I got a peaceful pro
which unlike a lot of these frauds
criticizing my cat once I've gotten old
system on Xbox with there some people or
cognitive acted like you didn't just get
another one but everyone's got their
preferred box that's what I'm trying to
say here yes right you clearly are every
month on ps4 the top 20 games are multi
platinum you like multi plats
we're all playing multi-platform the
rest of the year we know that alright
you're done with everything else you
know you know give us some props it's
not that hard it's something I am kind
of curious with this you know people
keep saying oh they got they got
exclusives they got exclusives look Sony
makes money off exclusives but they make
more money off licensing multi plats and
I think that's why they're gonna care
about this you know best place to play
multiplayer because you if it doesn't
really count for people that just have
you know an xbox or just have a
Playstation but there's a huge portion
of gamers that have both and those are
the ones that they're gonna start losing
market share when it comes to you know
third party games and let's be real here
you know maybe ten fifteen thousand go
away but it's not gonna be that there's
gonna be a lot of people that gravitate
towards the better call the better
platform to play that game on because it
happened the beginning of the generation
you know you people look at stuff like
digital foundry and when you keep seeing
these migration of these people going to
Xbox one X because they want to play it
on the best platform then you know they
are starting to lose that that software
cells that are losing those percentages
that and Sony does care about that they
care about that way more than they care
about the exclusives they have because
that's what's playing their bank that's
what's given the money is the the
drastically moreso games as third-party
well they think somebody's have more
they do have a big
selection more options more variety
that's true and we can't take that away
from them baby now can't go and take
performance away from Microsoft I bet I
bet you anything they make more money
off holiday yeah yeah then they make off
their exclusives the end of the day
listen it is one of those things where
you play with your friends are you
playing with the ecosystem that you like
and you know that they do offer variety
that that's a fact you know we can't we
can't say that but at the same time it's
like like lucky those saying it's like
if you want the best place to play these
multi plats and if you love the xbox
ecosystems and that's the spot for you
now the key is gonna be 2018 we see what
you know our only begotten Son Lord and
Savior you know I'm the I'm not a miss I
don't hate Phil I think feels a great
guy
you know I'm a big critic though and you
know obviously I always respect the fact
that the hand he was dealt from Don
Mattrick was a bad and what he's done to
turn the brand around if this 2013 III
y'all come on yeah I know that was not I
was talking to him over on a silver
platter and opening a poker with you
know five cards five high card and
coming out full outs was a jump you know
so I gotta give him that in the sea
division and I have to save right now
you know what all the negativity that
the X was getting for the majority of
the year it's good to see what's
happening right now and people actually
embracing the machine is starting to
support a little bit so like I said
let's just see what happens in 2018 he's
gotta bring us off right now but
Charlotte the Lord King I know that's
your guy he approached you know I was
giving them the vanilla and he was like
nah I don't want to hear that tell me
the truth you know
[Laughter]
even that side look like are you sure
I'm like no we all camera right now do
you really want this that you didn't
make it to YouTube no ankle when educate
he said Phil the snake I like I like
what he's doing he does what I like to
do like take away a narrative if your
narrative is this thing never even moved
and see what else you have to say now
they just told you they put 1 billion
dollars it's a game brother when these
games start to hit I don't want to hear
all Microsoft doesn't have first party
games and stuff like that anymore they
have the box they have the pedigree now
and moving forward just like Lord Lord
dealer said you plug in your controller
your headset
everything works there's no oh I need to
do this or I need to buy a different
thing or nothing this stuff works you
know what you know what the new thing is
gonna be right when all that happens is
it doesn't matter they have the card
they have the call of marketing they
have they have the battlefront marketing
they have the big third parties they
don't eat games or power I do have a
question you guys think Xbox will go get
the card marking exclusive bills again
no I think so shy away from it what do
you think dealer no no I mean they don't
even care to make their own games
exclusives anymore so let's close this
thing that we got football but you'll
shout out the Lord dealer for coming
through there big thing so glad to get
the support from you in it and like I
said the laws we definitely respects you
coming through so uh where can the fine
people find him
actually I want to ask you real quick
before we let you go to a reference we
didn't get the name would they tell me
about the deal a gaming name what's the
science behind that gamertag was I think
it was a deal or something [ __ ]
two-year-old would make and they kept
calling me either death or dealer and
said you know I'll choose one changed it
and then I made that my youtube name and
then I had to make sure that it had
something to do with what I was actually
doing on youtube so i put gaming behind
it simplistic answer he was ever gave
when it came to a name you know that's
what i do so yeah young guys appreciate
it and he just had cult on recently in
and i was able to for you guys it was a
good show I appreciate you I appreciate
you becoming to and what kind of find
people find you in that beautiful RDX
podcast yeah twitter is were basically
some early Sabri o podcasting saying
Twitter at dealer underscore gaming of
course at YouTube dealer gaming pretty
easy to find and just released a video
today during this podcast my twin did so
you know ice control future dealer nice
we have we got to get everybody to check
that out man like I said what this guy's
great content you know the whole team
over there self Luka all day call you
know I mean like shout out to these guys
like really really good podcast so we
definitely want to show I love and
support so uh Lord addict my coals with
Cole most what you got cooking anyway
can find people find you you can uh you
can find me mean-mugging uh Lord David
Lord addict I hope you can find me on
youtube gaming addict you can find me on
xbox broom to kill and you can now find
the old PlayStation you could definitely
catch me on the switch you know you can
find that somehow
Franco Social Security let's go I do
want to you know take thank delery for
coming through definitely we've we've
been walking you on for a while but you
know we've been we've been holding that
dealer card like we don't thank you
thanks again guys Lord saw a confront
people find you sir
oh sorry PSN ID is room to care I didn't
say that actually killed T Oh Kayla loss
off we're gonna find people fine sir
yeah we shout out the deal of man and
getting you up earlier we apologize for
that you know on the Sunday I think all
that was a dragon off beats of excited
lady NFL it was that was my fault man I
stayed up until like forever working on
a video on the paper is nah but I made a
Twitter Lord saw by Opie and online you
actually helped me it was just do what
he says Twitter Oh Xbox 360
level one was like was like oh oh or o3
took somebody took it
that's the best part about that is
another dude like me out there yeah I do
what I do want to take this like little
shot at PlayStation I was wanting to
make gaming addict you know on on
PlayStation but they don't but they
don't let you do spaces for some reason
so like I had to fall back on that dream
thanks a lot this again thanks for a
lower dealer coming through and you can
find me obviously on outlets mark I can
get on Twitter and actually on Xbox as
well as Laura Cognito and newly acquired
PSN pro from my man Lord King I'm
Carlito 360 there right that's about the
exit not as much but again shot to show
great great guess we got to pay the
bills right quick like I said when I hit
the like subscribe everybody supporting
it was in a circle networks in IOP
YouTube iTunes Google Play and of course
that amazing teaching in patreon the
link is in the description exactly
you'll shout out the Plantronics man we
got some more reviews coming
you know those rigs are out here moving
industry if you're trying to get
yourself a nice little headset right
there you know I'm saying make sure you
check them out the Rick 400 and the 800
and getting that beautiful crispy clear
dolby atmos y'all that are the Xbox one
EXO is a great way to maximize your
system we're gonna in this thing real
quick - I want to mention because it
absolutely deserves credit Microsoft's
new high bitrate high resolution game
DVR capture on the X absolutely that's
all straight from the DVR I plugged in a
flash drive in the back of the X I
recorded the clip I took it put it on my
PC and I that's xbox 1x DVR footage 4k
60 Wow looks amazing I mean it's nuts
to check it for you throw it out there
try it out but no the definitely check
it out shout the dealer for mention that
make sure you guys get on that maybe
four K movement is here and when I meant
we're gonna end this show everybody I'm
going peace